[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
comment ils les aident les biens mal et
mieux bienvenue dans les pas sorti de
l'auberge
aujourd'hui on est à saint pierre chez
sandrine sandrine va nous présenter son
exploitation d'agriculture bio mais
qu'en dit bio c'est bio de chez bio
alors donc des légumes de toutes les
couleurs de toutes les formes
bref vous allez venir avec moi ont droit
son green c'est parti
[Musique]
bonjour annexes comme les sandrine et là
ça va mais coûte déjà menacé d'appeler à
nous et l'exploitation mais content de
vous accueillir
je veux que je t'en prie dis moi où est
ce qu'on est
et qu'est ce que tu fais exactement
alors ici tu es sur une exploitation en
agroécologie appliqué au milieu tropical
certifié 100% biologique
boum c'est radical ça commence bien dis
moi on est devant l'aspect j'aurais
exactement ça commence bien
on garde ça 100 mètres carré d'as perge
ça un projet que j'ai menées en
expérimentation avec l'armée flore donc
tu vois les petites asperges qui sont là
donc on n'a pas de recul sur cette
culture à la réunion donc on a cinq
variétés d'aspères genre
d'expérimentations et au bout de trois
ans on verra celle qui qui s'adapte le
mieux à mon écosystèmes et puis voilà la
réunion et c'est prometteur parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'on récolte on compte on
calibre on marque tout ce qu'on récolte
et du coup dans trois ans on verra la
variété qui sera le plus adapté qui voit
le produit le mieux qui aura eu le moins
de maladies etc et on pourra peut-être
l'étendre sur d'autres exploitations du
mois sandrine qu'on rentre dans le vif
du sujet quand tu me dis bio et je vois
je te vois mais tu vois le madame là on
dirait mais alors elle est d'une espèce
dessus était comme celle dix mois c'est
bio en fait on va un petit peu plus loin
que le bio et voilà le cahier des
charges bio c'est un référentiel voilà
nous on va beaucoup plus loin on utilise
vraiment aucun insecticide à spectre
large même autorisé en bio et surtout
cherche la source de nos propres
amendements à nos sources de calcium de
son saut magnésium avec les végétaux
naturels endémiques de l'île
voila voila et puis je travaille surtout
depuis 12 ans dans le suivi de ma
biodiversité la faune et la flore et les
insectes sont très importants en
agriculture donc j'essaye d'avoir
déséquilibre d'insectes et aujourd'hui
on y arrive bien je suppose que c'est là
une petite partie de ce que tu fais
ouais bien sûr
on va voir on va voir leur est déjà
derrière toi tu vois le verger de
membres manquent josé bien sûr même
eyango monde
voilà voilà écoutons nous on évacue on y
va on leur attention à tout mais pas ça
[Musique]
qu'y voit on passe à côté on passe à
travers un verger de monk josé donc
l'année dernière il a très bien produit
et cette année j'ai une floraison
tardive mais ouais comme litchi encore
je me plains pas parce que je pense que
je vais faire 3 cape town demande quand
même ce sont 13 arbres en bio c'est joli
et c'est surtout le manque délicieuse en
amont que josé tu connais pas de vue
mais mes meilleurs mango monde
dis moi tu me parlais de thaler de
biodiversité de de cette passion tu as à
faire pousser les légumes les plantes
avec des techniques naturelles
tout à fait moi j'aimerais en savoir
monsieur plus sur les insectes nuisibles
et non une usine
tu vois dans la nature il n'y a pas de
mauvais insectes mais par contre quand
introduit une plantes maraîchères
eh ben elle va tirer un prédateur de
culture 1
un petit insecte qui va être piqueurs
suceurs ou enfin autour et qui va faire
des dégâts dessus mais dans la nature
naturellement il ya le prédateur de ce
prédateur de culture c'est ce qu'on
appelle des autres la colonne il ya le
prédateur du prédateur donc le but en
agroécologie c'est d'avoir suffisamment
de biodiversité suffisamment d
déquilibre d'insectes donc depuis dix
ans mon travail c'est de suivre
l'évolution de la faune et de la flore
sont mon terrain et à chaque fois que je
mets une culture en place de savoir
qu'est ce que ça va m'attirer comme
prédateur de culture et d'anticiper en
mettant des plantes de compagnonnage des
plantes pièges des pièges des barrières
mécanique
voilà quand tu vois bon ben on va les
voir bruno dans la serre parce que c'est
lui qui s'occupe justement des insectes
surexploitation on va le voir bruno qui
va nous montrer des insectes les petits
bébés
[Musique]
par cali alors dis-moi où est-ce qu'on
elle alors tu vois là on est dans ma
soeur de rage elle donc à toute une
gamme de bringel différentes tu vas voir
et où on avait nos tomates anciennes
1 cet hiver donc là on a tout enlevé on
va passer sur les curcubitacé donc tu
vas voir on a des croates longue de nice
là bas qui sont incroyables et puis
battu avoir toutes les qualités bringel
on a huit qualité bringel
[Musique]
sa célèbre âge elle aussi qui veut comme
ça bonjour monsieur bruno comment ça va
ça va très bien alors bruno dis moi
qu'est-ce que tu es en train de faire
alors on est en train de regarder ce que
c'est la punaise on a une petite punaise
ici qu'il faut la surveiller
c'est une petite punaise qui va manger
les aleurodes qui va manger un petit peu
les pucerons les thrips mais si elle a
pas suffisamment de nourriture
elle peut nous piquer soit les fruits
soient les tiges de nos courgettes
d'accord on regarde pour voir si la
population n'est pas trop importante et
si elle travaille bien si elle est en
train de nettoyer nos cultures tout ça
va nous permettre d'éviter de traiter
avec des produits même bio on laisse
d'abord nos insectes travailler ça prend
un petit peu plus de temps mais le
résultat il est là parce que la
population de pucerons est en train de
diminuer
à vue d'oeil
[Musique]
villaret vivre un truc bon match
oh
où
alex je voudrais te faire goûter quelque
chose absolument
t'es obliger ben il va faire tu me
fasses confiance alors dit moi tout tu
vas être bluffé voilà c'est ces petites
merveilles
bon je vais pas te dire ce que c'est
j'ai cassé une feuille et j'aimerais
bien qu à mettre entièrement dans ta
bouche toutes les feuilles rock
ouais tu croques tranquillement mais là
ne connaissez quoi comment vous voyez un
effet plus jettent à la bombe ont
annoncé vraiment goût d'huître on c'est
vrai qu'on a un goût du tout aussi alors
est ce qu'il faut c'est qu'ils trouvent
une salade exactement c'est une feuille
et 100 lieux
voilà c'est ça tissant llodra samedi au
cices et sa terre est ce que tu sens la
brigade et ça c'est une variété en fait
que tu ça c'est quelque chose que je
fais pour un chef ici d'accord cela
faire tu penses où les autres qu'ils
font je ne sais pas j'ai fait plein de
petites choses tu allais tu asperges
enfin légumes anciens
la marjolaine de syrie du piment renifle
mois sa monnaie basilic citron base
exutoire on a plein de petites choses
comme ça on bat
[Musique]
taschereau bas de 10 mois ce qui est à
peu près là en tout en poule à obala il
ya de la carotte il ya duras décolorés
dur et demie de c1 radiant siens à
quelques pieds de poivrons chocolat là
tu as des haricots beurre l'abaya la
motarde de chine un petit bout de wasabi
c'est intéressant ce samedi soir appelle
la paye
ce oui ils sont l'habitation mon père
chinois l'été qui veille vers khalid
l'invitation n'était pas besoin sur le
bronze pour toi est donné à moins d
basso à la panique elle est parti qu'il
est par dj matière voilà a dit qu'elle
ne l'est pas
on est posée tranquille je vais te poser
des petites questions sur l'exploitation
parce que je suis un petit peu curieux
déjà en fait j'aimerais savoir comment
tu es arrivé à faire ce métier avec ton
avec ton compagnon tout conjoint en fait
moi j'ai démarré
des études agricoles tout simplement par
passion
voilà un viticulture oenologie bts après
j'ai fait une école pour aller
travailler dans les pays en voie de
développement
et justement j'ai travaillé sur des
fermes en tout gérer ce qui m'a permis
de me spécialiser dans l'agriculture
tropicale à l'époque
et puis voilà je suis arrivé ici avec
mon premier mari en fait et
et j'ai démarré j'ai pu monter cette
exploitation 2005 en 2005 ici on parle
de bio tu parles aussi d'agroécologie
oui tu peux m'en dire un monsieur plus
en fait l'agroécologie tu vois c'est
l'étude de ton écosystèmes donc l'étude
de la faune et de la flore et du travail
de l'homme au sein de cet écosystème
donc t'as quand tu as bien compris tu as
biodiversité
quand tu la protèges qui lui permet de
se diversifier
tu es plus à même à faire des plantes
maraîchères au milieu de cet écosystème
ou des élevages où tous types
d'agricultures moi de comprendre les
interactions donc l'amour delmas et ce
quitte à emmener vers huy l'agroécologie
et puis parce que l'agro écologie c'est
un modèle de développement un qui prend
aussi en compte l'homme
la valorisation du métier de paysan
redonner ses lettres de noblesse au
monde paysan toi l'agroécologie te
permets tout ça fait beau je resterai
ici
à t'écouter pendant des heures me parler
des manques josé me parler des
aubergines et des insectes mais je
reviendrai en plus regarde sa marmaille
un petit pied de petit bois bon que je
mets dans ma poche quoi moi je pars avec
moi à la prochaine alex north oui merci
à plus tard nous retrouvons nontron
[Musique]
et oui messieurs dames
l'émission se termine c'est comme ça
c'est la vie mais je reviendrai promis
juré
alors je précise que sandrine fait son
petit marché le samedi matin
d'accord sur place donc avec des légumes
toutes sortes de petites salades etc
donc vous êtes invités bien sûr à venir
nombreux 1 un lieu de rencontre
magnifique je vous dis au revoir à la
prochaine et petite précision très
importante
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge ben non
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
parce que quand ils rentrent dans la crm
a maintenant une espèce de moutarde
chinoise un truc comme ça l'une à faire
dans la bouche s'affaisse bigboo
[Musique]